la plus grande angoisse de gilles verdez
il nous l'a dit sur ce plateau est ce
que vous vous rappelez de la plus grande
angoisse de gilles verdez c'est
impossible mais moi je m'en souvenais
plus intégré les clowns
non c'est pas des conneries il a déjà 10
et non pas le vide non non sinon ils
seraient ils travaillent pas mais trois
noms d'isabelle pas sans rappeler je
crois isa match est rythmé à mr gilles
ce mondial intervient alors qu il a
l'air en forme mais oui gilles verdez sa
plus grande angoisse
regardez c'est ça si un jour vous voulez
vie régit les bains je vous jure je
viens de découvrir un truc qui le rend
malade mais qui le rend malade
il a fait ça dans un restaurant le
restaurateur la porte et un truc il est
parti en renversant une table tellement
il était fou de rage et vous savez ce
que c'était fait quoi je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'était des endives braisées
des choux de bruxelles
non non vous êtes on dit vaut fob je
vous ai je vous ai déjà parlé des clowns
blancs mais ça je peux pas en parler et
un clash j'ai envie de vomir
j'avais comment elles sont mais audibles
son brésil va me faire vomir série
d'accords alors là vous vous dites est
ce qu'il va se passer
eh bien gilles était avec trip note
heather xavier klaus que vous
retrouverez d'ailleurs le 27 novembre à
21 en streaming à l'apollo théâtre pour
votre show qui s'appelle laisse
hypnotiser heures son show c'est
exceptionnel et sera en tournée dans
toute la france au site
gilles en fait à chaque fois que veut
dire le mot sa phobie chez pas la dire
tout de suite il vira en fait à chaque
fois que tu veux dire le nom et le
prénom de cette personne qui est là les
petits yeux il le verra comme ça comme
ça il le verra comme ça s'il vous plaît
aux gars oui il le devra comme ça c'est
déjà très bien commencé mais il n'est
pas m'as bien et vous très bien vous
aider à benjamin castaldi
alors pour le désactiver venir
fatoumatou non fat ou non ses pizzas
finalement pizza pizza fragiles marais
vous qu'est ce que vous avez vu est allé
clown blanc et surtout les endives
braisées je peux pas supporter ça c'est
un truc cci phobie l'odeur le laver et
là bas vous m'avez mines endives
braisées elle était là elle était là
lors du boisé oui là il y avait une
envie braisé ah oui voulait venir à côté
de moi avait la cote et moi donc tu
montes dans sa main tout se mange et là
attention les dégâts au coeur et à plus
dans des brises et la non attention il
ya plus dandy brésil inquiéter un peu
dandy de la pizza ça vous avez vraiment
peur d en librairie mais pourquoi que ce
qui serait une phobie c'est une phobie
du goût de l'eau d'or est en fait je
suis désolé mais quand vous de parler ou
quand je vois ça quand je parle ça me
fait des vomissements des nausées des
ses phobies terrible cérémonie de goût
de tout ça là vous le voyez là vous
voyez qu'il n'ya pas de temps dix
blessés
yakhi la benjamin et je connais lui rien
là que la prétendue presser très haut
non on va essayer de vaincre votre
phobie des endives braisées je peux
retourner ma sera bien sûr au chili tout
ce que vous voulez savoir mon schéma
vous aimez le pauvre il est revenu enfin
qu'on aimerait vaincre sa phobie des cdd
des endives braisées j'espère qu'après
ça oui peut-être que vous allez pouvoir
revoir des endives braisées mais oui le
travail que va faire notre hypnotiseur
mais vraiment quand vous êtes dans un
restaurant vous voyez des endives
braisées je peux passer cc c'est un truc
c'est plus qu'un dégoût c'est un rejet
en fait c'est une pulsion de rejet je
suis désolé parce que c'est pas mais
c'est une pulsion de rejet jeu cet été
difficile avec anton en valeur expliqué
ce qu'il faut que vous sachiez c'est que
chez lui chez vous gilles à chaque fois
qu'on dit le nom de cette personne
ils le voient en costume avec une tête
d'andy oise et c'est ça une envie braisé
non je veux plus voir et nous voyons nom
d'ici là il ya eu tout à l'heure il ya
une endives braisées rival à lui mis sa
tête
oui il y avait une sorte de
deux de gros corps anna mae au dessus
avait vu l' on va tout faire pour
vaincre votre phobie demande y voisine
et un jour pour les restaurants seront
ouverts
je vous inviterai et on mangera ensemble
des endives braisées vous verrez ça ira
mieux d'accord cette peur parce que
c'est plus possible non d'accord oui je
ne vais plus dire son nom
non hakim bas à lui moi on l'appelle
petit oeil
d'accord elle gilles est ce que ça va
mieux ça va mieux ça va me moucher rully
je suis rassuré moi j'aime bien être là
non mais a serré oui merci gilles gilles
ça va très bien et vous oui très bien on
a peur pour lui les chevaliers ceux qui
vivent un collègue isabelle c'est vrai
ou pas cette histoire mais à mais oui
mais moi j'étais avec lui un jour où
j'ai vu mouvement et moi j'en plus j'en
riais je me dis lui atteint moi j'ai
encore sans plus et effectivement
c'était une psycho dont moi
souvenez-vous all one qui avait peur des
bananes sur ce plateau sorti en courant
parce qu'ils avaient montré l'armée moi
la vraie rigolade c'est que gilles voit
quand même benjamin castaldi ces
personnes comme ça donc à chaque fois
qu'on lui attribue
il le voit au nom du président gilbert
days on va s'occuper de vous mon chéri
notre hypnotiseur va guérir et vous
aurez plus la phobie des endives
braisées d'accord manger on en voit si
avec ça ira mal oui vous voulez être
guéri oui eh ben on va tout faire pour
mon fils parce que je vous aime en plus
très très fort aussi
merci manger voilà merci on peut la
retenir les crocs
[Applaudissements]